what's up everybody go to
christycomedy.com i'm back on the road
the chrissy theaters everybody hashtag
cte tour has started baby january 22nd
tampa theater this saturday tampa tony
will be there on stage with me he said
he's going to wear short shorts and his
diabetic socks pulled up to his nutsack
so be in tampa at the tampa theater this
saturday january 22nd then january 29th
we're at the borgata that's almost sold
out in atlantic city february 5th
at the beacon theater in new york city
tt jerry's coming on stage she said
she's going to pee on the front rows to
wear a poncho february 11th the warner
theater washington dc february 12th
homeless pimp's birthday show the
tabernacle theater atlanta georgia and
then we got march uh fourth and fifth in
cleveland and detroit go to
chrisdcomedy.com for tiki wiki's fine
yard city portland seattle everybody's
on there indianapolis philadelphia who
gives a
we're going crazy christy comedy.com
let's have some fun guys in a couple of
weeks i will be coming to detroit and
pittsburgh february 11th and 12th second
shows were added there so get your
tickets a couple of weeks of the next
week after that february 18th and 19th
i'm at albany at the egg and washington
dc at the capital one hall and then to
close out feb february 26th and 27th we
are in madison at the barrymore and
chicago at the vic we've added second
shows to all of those get tickets right
now at southvolcanocomedy.com
don't be a fake don't be a flake don't
run away from your feelings babe don't
be afraid don't be ashamed don't
hesitate to say hey babe hey babe hey
babe hey babe
[Music]
bermuda bahama come on staten island key
largo montego baby why don't
hey babe hey baby
so now you and i
we
you we're at we're doing the same thing
we're at different points you just got
into the show yellowstone which i have
gotten all the way through and love it
i just have gone into succession which
you have gotten all the way through and
you love it yeah so we're at where it it
it's an it's one of those things where i
gotta be honest
i am in
a good mood yeah today like the fact
that i have a new show now to binge it
actually does things to my endorphins
and my brain sure i'm genuinely excited
about doing the podcast with you today
going down to the comedy cell doing my
shows and then coming home and putting
on an episode you have a place to put
your energy i have a place to put my
energy because or else it's just like
what am i watching what am i doing i'm
scrolling on my phone now it's like i'm
into succession yeah i agree with you
hundred percent when i don't worry about
yellowstone i do when i don't have
something to fall back on and i i
finally get a moment to breathe at the
end of the day like i shove down like
nine o'clock i get in front of the
television and it's the worst feeling to
be like what do i watch everybody start
just scrolling through everything yeah
and you start something it sucks you
start something else then all of a
sudden two hours pass you gotta go to
bed and i just it's so
annoying no but but and what's beautiful
about yellowstone yeah again you could
talk about succession but just because
i'm too yellowstone what yellowstone has
done
crazy thing yellowstone now
they have a a show they have a show
within a show they have yellowstone and
then they have the show 1883.
i saw a commercial for it did it just
start wait until you see the episode of
yellowstone randomly one yellowstone one
one freaking episode just starts like
they're in 1883 in the wild wild west
you're like what the hell's going on
and it's basically kevin costner's great
great great great grandfather that's an
entire show wow i want to be an origin
story if you will my boys shout out
paddy fly balls and little debo
texted me two nights ago
they texted me two nights ago and i was
already asleep it was one of those
nights where my kids actually uh we
dropped them off by
my mom's house so we had a night where
like we had the kids weren't in the
house we felt we were like we're gonna
do this we're done fell asleep at 8 30
at night woke up at seven o'clock in the
morning just because you're like so
exhausted yeah but at about 8 50 at
night let's say i got a text from my boy
uh pat finnegan like hey we're at the
msg rodeo the rodeo is at msg it's going
on a little bit longer do you want to
come and i was like if i would have
gotten that text i would have bolted
from madison square garden to go to msg
he went to a rodeo and they put on the
cowboy hats and everything next year
especially after you watching
yellowstone yeah and pimp you got a
couch-up too let's make it a plan a
point to go to the rodeo i would love it
i want to go to the one never in my life
we filmed that one it was the only one
i've ever gone to where was it in uh
yeah it was in uh san antonio oh wow at
a place called uh yeah the road and
there's a there was a steakhouse
attached to it called tejas
had one of the top three best stakes
i've ever had in my life they do these
like like wagyu beef tips anyway
uh do they still tie the nuts is that
it's a fallacy cowboy do they tie the
nuts let's google that pimp do do they
do the nuts get tired of what the bowl
are we talking about right i heard they
tied them real tight and that's what
they're doing they're trying to like
they're bucking because they want to get
out of the flank strap is not tied
around the bull's testicles aka nuts
this rope is to encourage the bull to
use his hind legs more in a buck bucking
motion as this is a true test of a
rider's skill in maintaining the rod
are we saying that was a fallacy
nuts
everyone knows about the tide nuts not
in the type of rodeos we're going to
maybe an underground rodeo the bulls
nuts are getting tied but not
not if we're on the up and up
okay bulls nuts wow
have you ever seen somebody castrate a
pig
just twice
there's a video of it it's like they
catch wild hogs i don't know if i want
to see it because they don't want them
overpopulating because they eat the
vegetation and they castrate a pig like
while it's like they tie it up and they
castrate it and then they just let the
pig go it's not a local anesthetic
antiseptic or an esteem shouldn't give
them nothing give them wine it's it's
it's crazy wait they can't just let the
wound bleed they'll bleed out google but
they'll bleed out google wild hog
castration video
[Music]
your search history is going to get
you're going to get raided by look at
this look at this here's joe derosa um
[Laughter]
by the way a warthog
what is that guy saying what was this
this is very a wild boar will get
castrated in this video the board gets
revenge
what does that mean oh mike well it's
just started out with his kid in a car
seat they the boar stole the guy's
credit a couple years later it's what it
is go okay so he's so he don't know he's
got him this is a walk
that is so women why did you watch this
that is so wrong
pimp it's getting
he doesn't know what's happening he
doesn't know what's happening but i
think that he does this because i think
that it's one of the see what how does
he get revenge though what does he do
does he [__] bite him
it would be great if he castrates the
guy oh what happened why did he just run
away he just ran away what happened
let's see why he ran away
he ran away as to not get attacked i'm
sure wait this guy's smiling
what is this guy this guy's an [__] i
mean
he's two million views does he have does
he have authority to do that or is he
doing that role no i think that i think
because when i looked at the comments of
this video there was a lot of people
being like i know it looks bad but it's
it's like a sterilization thing uh
because of the mass reproduction they
have i think they kill i think they mess
up the ecosystem but but that could just
be human [__] but they couldn't have
put like uh uh a numbing agent on the
balls first what would you put i mean
like i don't know just like a throw some
icy hot on it yeah or like uh uh
novocaine like a topical get a dentist
out there like a lidocaine or something
by the way speaking of dentist i still
have to get the other side of my mouth
cleaned i've only cleaned one side of my
mouth and i've canceled multiple
appointments
they know where you live
[Laughter]
oh because you would you you couldn't
get through it because you're going to
get through it yeah but but i'm going to
do it i'm going to do it do you feel the
difference
the left side of my mouth feels better
than the right side of mouth genuinely
genuinely i have less
tooth pain on the left side of my mouth
yeah so i brought up five facts about
cowboys yeah okay i actually knew this
first fact
this is something very interesting i
actually knew this somehow many cowboys
had been civil war soldiers from both
the north and the south and many others
perhaps up to a quarter of all cowboys
were freed ex-slaves some cowboys were
from europe and others were mexicans and
american indians but the thing about
like the wild wild west yeah you know
like when you say like jesse james
billy's kid all of them were
ex-confederate soldiers that the reason
why that happened to them was because
they were shunned and there was no work
for them so they just were like well we
gotta go west and because they were you
know confederate soldiers and used to
like a certain type of way of life they
were just like we're just going to be
outlaws like they were outlaws so it's
like the reason why you have the wild
west is you know because of the
confederacy i just always thought that
that was interesting because like you
can't make somebody fight in a war like
it's even in the north the civil war
soldier and then just like hey just go
sit go sell insurance right it's like no
i just killed people with fire what am i
to do now you know what i mean i think
sal would have an issue being a cowboy
just because of this fact here here's
this fact cowboys often wore their
clothes for weeks without changing they
wore denim jeans with chaps to protect
their legs from the thorny branches
their horses rode through oh my god
forget about it sal wearing wearing wool
wearing the boots and the whole cowboy
getup in in the in the in the texas heat
oh with all that sweat
he hates sweat
dirt and general uncleansiness you're
not a cowboy they wore a bandana around
their neck which they could pull up to
protect their nose and mouth from trail
dogs their wide rim stetson hats
protected them from the sun's glare and
also served as a cup
they'd used to scoop water for both
themselves and their horses to drink out
of at night once the cattle were bedded
down and quiet two men on guard might
slowly circle around and sing calm to
them
wow would you guys rather be a cowboy or
a truck driver
i guess a cowboy
this day and age cowboy or an outlaw
cowboy
well
i'd rather be cowboy is your opponent oh
cowboys were the original truck drivers
in a way yeah in a way yeah by the way
if if
if
this was 200 years ago our audience
would be cowboys
yeah pretty much they're sitting there
they're on the ranch they're they're
going you know delivering the mail
they're delivering products
they just got a little hey baby i'll be
a modern day cowboy i'd be my
driving's tough man that's tough in the
show and yeah
cowboy looks like a pretty fun job yeah
it looks nice i mean it's it's long
hours i wasn't expecting i don't know
much about cowboy life don't know much
about cowboy life
[Laughter]
don't know much about herd and cattle um
but i do know all right i'll stop it uh
i don't know much about it and i watched
it and do you think that how much of
that do you think is there's some truth
to the yellowstone in in those areas
high concentration of billionaires still
fighting over land still fighting with
natives well that is that is the truth
about montana i heard this might not be
100 true but i heard that show is
actually filmed on kevin costner's
actual ranch wow that is his actual for
real ranch he lives out there yeah i
heard that that's what he did you know
can i also ask you a question and this
may be very easy
novice question and i don't know if we
might have even asked us on the last hey
baby did we ask why cows have to be
herded
like every day
the cowboys in the show the cowboys have
to wake up everybody's going to be heard
they're going to be heard i need to be
heard but why do they make a move they
said oh we're going to go up through you
know junction yellow stone pet but why i
think we have to move them i'm guessing
could it be that they eat all the grass
where they are so they move to get new
food aka brush and grass yeah but isn't
after a while they're just going to eat
all the grass or is that why you need a
big place i don't know it's like fifty
thousand acres
i i can't see because it's rick flair
grazing areas
yeah they want them to eat at certain
toward favorable grazing areas hurting
also involves keeping the heart safe and
predators and natural dangers oh maybe
like they move them so like word doesn't
get out like the hyenas are not like
there's [__] cows down there right
right they're going to be there all
month
you know that cows
really are just for human consumption
there's we don't there's no reason for
them
aren't there guests an issue actually
yeah that's why they blow farts in the
their farts blow holes in the ozone
layer right because that's the thing if
fart girl really wants to impress i mean
get up to a cow fart your fart start
blowing holes in the ozone layer i'll
buy a jar of farts yeah a thousand
dollars it's like it's cheap a thousand
dollars but
look was a cow created yeah see this is
what i'm saying go down go down a little
bit says here that humans uh through
breeding have manipulated the cow right
become something else yeah that's what
i'm saying like this they're not natural
they're not like horses are not natural
to um to america either
they're not no they came over in spain
and the first time in a while or
like a stallion or something from over
there yeah there's a couple of places
though in the world where like horses
are wild like like there's not most
horses are domesticated but there's a
couple places in the earth they run free
where it's like a horse is just born and
never domesticated it's like a wild
animal where is that where are wild
horses where can we see wildlings i'd
like to do a podcast i'd like to do a
podcast from there
let's do extreme ironing on the back of
a wild horse
oh wow they're found in the united
states nevada is home to more than half
of the wild horse population in north
america so in nevada you're going to
vegas okay i could see colorado montana
nevada utah even oregon and wyoming
california
arizona wild you guys ever drive through
an open range with those have you seen
wild horses pimp travels all over you've
actually seen wild horses but how do you
know they're not on somebody's farm
because there's like highways that are
marked like wild like wild like open
range i mean they could be owned land i
don't know
who is a horse's natural predator
um
anybody
i don't think anything can kill a horse
besides like a lion a cat or something
yeah but yeah but they're not in there
in the united states there's no big cats
a horse depends on uh it's natural uh
ability to outrun wolves and bears but
yeah i was going to say the horse can
outrun anyone
yeah but sometimes when you get like a
pack of wolves running around signing
out your heels yeah and then yeah it
just takes one mountain lions yeah
mountain lions are nasty
and why don't i guess we do have
mountain lions horses need shoes
like a wild horse is never going to have
a horseshoe but why don't why do
domesticated horses need shoes just for
dignity you think that's what it is just
like put a shield
you don't want that the horse is walking
all over here barefoot i mean would you
live in a barn
they strengthen and protect the hooves
and feet and to prevent the hoos from
wearing down too quickly wild horses
will wear the hooves will wear their
hooves down gradually as they move from
place to place over hard arid terrain so
is that if you're a wild horse is that
what's going to die is you're going to
wear your hooves down yeah and then
you're just you're just walking on nubs
yeah maybe maybe maybe no maybe that
really maybe that's a big issue for wild
horses i think that might be maybe the
answer to your question is
the natural predator tool to a horse is
it's hooves so it's it's feet it's its
own it's his own
worst enemy a question
what do they do to the horse to put the
shoe on is it is it asleep they have a
scene in yellowstone where they show it
they nail they pretty much crucify the
horse they nail it into his foot i know
it's nails but like is the horse just
watching it i don't know but they say
that the horse doesn't feel it because
their hooves are made of jello
right
jello
isn't
jell-o gelatin isn't gelatin isn't when
you eat bill cosby's jell-o isn't it
horse hoof i always hear the gelatin has
animal product in it but i didn't know
if it was hoof
huff
my name is aubrey huff not aubry huff
i'm aubrey huff
yeah they
i can't do it
i was going all in on the dad joke oh
just do it huffington post was going to
be the first time
[Laughter]
um like your hair and fingernails horse
hooves keep growing all the time so
maybe they don't wear out necessarily in
fact horses grow the equivalent of a new
hoof about once a year is it hoof now
is it hoof or hoof it's hoof
i think it's hoof and hooves it's hot i
think multiple hoofs are hooves
hooves but not hooves
horse hooves horseholes it's a horse
huff i'm behooved
hoof what about hooves hooves who have
subs oops
oh they're not going to give us no
hooves
h-o-o-v-e-s
is it hooves or hoofs
hoops
hooves here we go
oh it is hit it hit it looks like it's
saying hooves
the horn
puffs pubs not not hooves hooves hoof
and hooves
hooves
okay so so they grow the equivalent of a
huff a hoof
every year every year they're going a
full hub so then if they have uh
horseshoes on uh are they also says no
nerve endings in the hoop so they don't
feel
the shoe being put on but how do they
know do they rest the horse once they
yeah not really
so once they put on a shoe and then the
horse grows the equivalent of a whole
new hoof they have to get new shoes
every year that's what i'm saying like
we did with school
they get new shoes they get new shoes a
horse gets new shoes every year they're
like they're like yeah they're like um
yeah i mean why isn't nike making horse
hoof why isn't nike making horseshoes
hooves they should call them new product
line seriously
do you think do you think it's out of
the realm of possibility where at some
point someone like a kanye west is going
to make a type of yeezy that's shaped
like a horse hoof
is it out of the realm of possibility
that that we are living in a time where
there will be a sneaker that's made to
look like a horseshoe have you seen the
shoe name it looks like it's there
already
what is this show now
i mean this is someone has to say hey
this is not
thirteen hundred dollars this shoe is
is he laughing at everybody is he like
you absolute idiots like this whole time
it's a bit i get it it looks like a moon
boot i get that it's very like maybe
fashion forward but
you're really committing to a look there
i would nev this is his latest uh thing
he's wearing everywhere these fishing
boots he has somebody saw them wearing
on his concert with drake yeah yeah
she's wearing galoshes yeah galoshes
those are not hits those have been
around forever i have galoshes you have
collages i used to wear galoshes really
yeah i actually just bought my niece and
nephew collages for uh what's what's up
what's your go-to galosh brand
um i forget what it's called
they're the ones we had even when we
were little that you could get at army
navy stores they're green oh yeah army
green with like a yellow line around the
bottom a great look uh by the way
speaking of uh looks and stuff a lot of
you guys have been messaging me i'm sure
that hey babe account message me what is
the pillow company uh that i mentioned
with sal and you keep asking me to give
you the information i'm just gonna say
here on the pod it's very easy just
google it it's hum locker and schmuckle
that's what it is yeah so ham locker and
schmuckles
that's what it is so just google that
it's easy to spell yeah um by the way i
saw this yesterday it's just kind of
cool it's like crime in the future
model brooks nader
among women who say apple air tags are
used to stalk them you know what's so
crazy about this i was sitting in my
house
three days ago and i got an alert that
said apple air tag near you and i said
what the hell i said did somebody did i
get air tagged tt jerry
is house watchings or doing something
with a friend their keychain has an
apple air tag on it so i had no idea but
this is like a new thing you can get you
can get air tagged without you have no
idea you got tabs i thought you had to
turn on a setting maybe but the premise
is that if they leave their [__]
somewhere like on some random block or
something it'll alert other you could
use other iphones to ping it okay you
can track it like let's say i bought it
and i put in my suitcase that got lost
by united yeah i could yeah united by
the way losing suitcases one person at a
time
i can instantly see where my tag is but
what's going on in philly what happened
this woman is there people are walking
behind you slipping it in your coat if
you look rich
and when you walk away they can track
that tag that's in your coat then go rob
your house they're also putting it
underneath your car in magnet boxes
and then what and then when you pull
your lamborghini home for the night and
go to sleep they know well i'll tell you
what this is my mind as a parent i'm the
father of two daughters and i will pay
the their ob gyn
top dollar to
put an
uh uh apple air tag in as an iud and
then i'll always know where they are and
what's going on and if the air tag is
moved or
you'll know something's going on
so that's all i'll keep track of my kids
is i'm going to somehow get an apple
here by the time my kids my girls are 16
the apple air tag i can probably get it
i could probably put in their [__]
orange juice it's not gonna be
appalachia it's gonna be the apple
like person tag yeah that's gonna just
what it is well it's pretty tiny have
you seen this yeah i've seen no i saw
them on the keychain
i thought they were cool i thought i
thought about buying them as a gift uh
brand new like how how i think they're
competing you remember the tile tile was
the competitor it was like a square just
a square white thing it's the same exact
concept the reason i i thought it was so
cool at first because you could the tile
you could slide in your wallet it's
almost like as thin as a credit card
okay so you can't lose your wallet but
then it was it was only up to the
bluetooth so if you walk 30 or 100 feet
away it'll vibrate and you're like oh
[__]
my phone's vibrating i must have left my
wallet somewhere but once you pass it i
didn't think you could ping it anymore
right i think with this it's like but by
the way i mean tracking devices and
these kind of things have been around
forever forever i just i just think that
maybe they're just like now it's like a
pack for for fifty dollars it's cheap as
hell man to travel it's like
that's like available to like mass
production like it's available to the
masses well it's just so funny how
something cool comes out and creeps use
it
weaponize it immediately yeah yeah
that's why you can't have any good thing
you ever think about like like listen i
i try to be as good of a person as i can
i i know this i don't always make the
right choices and you know there's no
mistakes that i've made but if everybody
in the world i know was like me
there would be no cr like nobody
everybody would be safe like you
wouldn't have to i would never try to
misuse something like that i would never
hurt someone i would never try to rob
anyone i would never you know rape
anybody i would never murder someone i
would never do these things but i'm just
saying like it gets me mad sometimes or
i'm like why can't everybody just be
like me and then we could all just
[__] relax i know cause you got
[__] out there that want to do
stupid [__] but are you only you if you
grow up around your exact circumstances
nurture nature if you take you you as
you and you grew up somewhere else are
you coming out the same way
right you just mean everyone's like you
are right now because you don't want to
harm anything you always have good
intentions
that's what the thing is like most most
women like murders are committed like 99
by guys right yeah like is that like
wars are started by men it's all men
it's all men yeah it's all men yeah i
mean i mean every war you've we've ever
seen in our lives was pretty much
started by one guy that got mad at
another guy and then it just spilled
over into [__] yeah but you know
with that being said i'm happy hillary
clinton's not president um no i'm
getting imagine i'm just kidding
all this technology is getting really
creepy like i saw in california this
woman found out that the smoke detector
that's been in her apartment forever was
a camera really you know what it got uh
the guy who did this call it the janitor
came in for no reason
and then said oh i changed the batteries
in the smoke alarm in this in this
unit
and then he left the smoke alarm hanging
and her boyfriend went to play with it
and there was a camera in there oh so it
wasn't the janitor no it had to be the
janitor
who else would service because on the
back of the smoke alarm look what it's
in their bedroom oh look at the angle i
was gonna say in their bedroom but i
guess you can't prove it was the
javascript holy [__] they pulled down
the smoke alarm and look what it said on
the back of the soap
i can't read that it says this is not a
smoke detector this is a video device
not a smoke detector
wow that's been hanging on this angle
over their bed the entire time they live
there
so what happened
she tried to report it to the police and
like nobody's helping this lady well i
guess because it says on the thing while
this is you have to read the fine print
of
i don't know i don't know i mean where
are they getting this feed did they hook
it up to their own no because it records
to an sd card in so the whole like 1080
camera and recording unit is in the
smoke alarm so in other words that it
wasn't getting fed to anyone it wasn't
live streaming out but every few months
they were like the janitor did check on
the smoke alarm
so why isn't he in jail they're i mean i
think they're going through the motions
now this is like from last week wow
oh that is terrifying yeah yeah i mean i
mean the thing is true the truth the
truth the situation is you can have
um
i mean video cameras are so microscopic
now we could be filmed anywhere what
happened to a friend of mine what
happened a friend and her husband this
was years ago uh went to a hotel and
then found themselves online
really really what are the chances i
know how
the story was that
she told me that they they after the
fact
they saw themselves online
and that there was a camera in what the
hotel they were in
in their room like i suppose what i mean
the hotel is just to sue them this i i i
don't know all the details of it but it
was it was like it's common on an adult
site you get what i'm saying oh they
were having they were intercourse yeah
they were having relations between two
adults consensual yeah yeah right
wow that's um that's that's that's very
good that's scary how often do you gotta
realize like if anyone who hosts an
airbnb could spend 30 on amazon yeah
that's the thing about airbnbs man
that's the thing about everybody i've
been reading articles about that
airbnb's business is going down i
believe right
i mean it's kind of how could it not be
a setup half the time a lot of people
are using it for like you know
to shoot adult films or do it's always
something sketchy it's never i i've used
i've used that version of airbnb vrbo
which by the way i thought it was vrbo
and i saw a commercial that was like
verbo yeah i always thought it was verbo
there's vrbl and and the like there's a
couple other ones i've used them all
i've had from for one time or another
for different reasons and i'd say
eighty percent of the time there's major
issues with your airbnb yeah yeah it's
like not clean things don't work the
pool's broken the the they don't have
utensils something's filthy like it's
it's not as advertised eight out of ten
times
maybe it's not a
uh like a uh
a deal breaker half the time it is but
then other times like all right they'll
try to work to fix it and then the first
day you're on the phone with them i'm
waiting for the hotel always yeah i
always opt for the talk i use it uh i
use it download the app to my phone and
i use it every week in football season
to make my little flip my the football
games more enticing to me you know i
have a reason to watch every game now
you know that giving all the new
customers a free shot and millions of
dollars in total prizes with the first
deposit did you know that i do now and
if sportsbook isn't available in your
state yet
uh your new year can still be great
because everyone can play for huge cash
prizes with draftkings daily fantasy
basketball contest download the
draftking sportsbook app right now use
the promo code hey babe bet just five
dollars on any nba team and win 150
dollars in free bets if they're
victorious that's another promo code hey
babe this that's promo code hey babe an
official sports betting partner of the
nba draftking sports books now here's
the thing must be 21 or older new jersey
indiana indiana must be 21 or older in
new jersey indiana indiana indiana
it must be 21 years or older new jersey
indiana or pennsylvania only new
customers only minimum five dial deposit
and a one dollar wager required one per
customer restriction supply see
draftkings.com sportsbook for details
gambling problem
call 100 gamblers
babe feels cbd have you heard about this
i heard about it i got it downstairs
dude it's the best it keeps my head
clear
it's been proven to greatly reduce my
anxiety pain and sleeplessness i've
tried other cbd products to me to be
honest with you feels is the best i have
it downstairs i i have a bottle of it
it's tincture the one i have it's a
little oil and it tells you how many
drops you need for what you want to
apply it to and you put it under your
tongue and so if i want to get extra
sleep or i want to like if i have some
pain or i just want to relax it's a
different amount of drops i've been
doing it the last few days and you know
cbd is right for you it's a if what
feels what i like about them is they're
they're a membership program and it's
hassle-free and it's guaranteed to help
you feel your best month after month or
your money back it's that
simple um it helps reduce stress anxiety
pain and sleeplessness it's shipped
directly to your door and only a few
days it's new it's natural and it's a
healthy way to feel better uh cbd is
everywhere now it has exploded it's
genuinely so you want to make sure that
you know where you're getting it from
and who you're buying it from and feels
is the real deal in fact feels offers
free cbd a free cbd hotline to help
guide your personal experience so that
you find the perfect dose their customer
service team is dedicated to making sure
you get the best use of it uh joining
the fields monthly membership makes you
makes your self-care easy you'll save
money and every order and you could and
you could pause any or cancel any time
or pause anytime which is what i like
start feeling better right now with
feels become a member today by going to
fields that's f e a l s dot com slash
hey babe and you're gonna get 50
off your first order with free shipping
i mean what do you got to lose take a
little cbd yeah yeah that's
feals.com hey babe to become a member
and get 50
automatically taken off your first order
with free free shipping
fields.com hey babe pimp you had a
horrible experience with an airbnb the
picture that it looked like were you in
austin yeah i was going to film shane
gillis comedy special and i booked like
a nice i thought big like condo for me
and a friend and we showed up and it was
like
cockroaches for some reason the the
bathtub was filled with like maybe 200
wet towels 200 what time like it was
disgusting and then i called the guy who
said yeah what's wrong
and then i called the airbnb i sent two
photos of what it looked like and they
immediately said evacuate the premise
did you ever get your money back oh yeah
airbnb was like oh no that's not right
my biggest nightmare i actually didn't
end up reporting to them i rented a
rented a house on the water in fort
lauderdale because your report after
week i report but we came back from the
cruise and i had my whole family with me
and some friends so i got i wanted to
find like a place that we could all stay
for a few days what city are we in in
fort lauderdale okay and i found this
one like right on the water like where
the dock is right on the back it was
really great and it looked beautiful and
i got there it turns out lo and behold
they just flipped the house
nobody went in to do anything with it so
it was like prior it was that to that it
was vacant we came in there was no
utensils the pots and pans were filthy
there was dirt everywhere the pool
heater didn't work there was bedrooms
that like they didn't show you in the
pictures that were absolutely awful and
then i the kicker was
i found blood dried blood in the place
on the tail and then the kicker the
kicker was i went i opened one room and
there was a it was a fire prior in there
and it was like you saw fire damage on
the wall and the room had all garbage in
it and it was like the walls were
carpeted it was odd it was like it was
like they didn't remodel it and it was
like literally a crime scene in there
and it was smelled and there was all
burn marks and everything and i was like
what is this room what'd you do i was
just like what and they were like oh
just don't go in that room but then i
got the guy on the phone i was like
i'm gonna report like this is my whole
family's here we just walked in the
place is disgusting right and he was
like some douchey like california real
estate guy that could care less and he's
like yeah i'll help you out i'll help
you out he took it like that and then he
he didn't really help and then in the
end i had to fight with him to get like
half discounted and he didn't even want
to do it he he went from like i'll help
you to like like making it like like i
was being a dick
how
like i was demanding of him it was
unreasonable what i was asking for from
him but it was disgusting
absolutely i wanted to report him but
like i was already there it was i didn't
know what to do and then he looked took
half of it off and they tried to fix
some [__] it was terrible it was
terrible i found raw chicken in the ice
outside there was like a like a place
where you cook with the barbecue and not
like the fridge and stuff there was raw
chicken in the ice like literal chicken
cutlet uncooked in the ice contaminated
anyway
you couldn't even eat it no we never
used the whole thing we couldn't use it
the the
the barbecue outside didn't even work
so what did you how long did you stay
there three nights so you stayed so you
wind up saying there was no everything
was booked there was nowhere for us to
go i had 19 people or whatever it was in
one we rented like a mansion
and so we kind of like took the discount
we ourselves went clean things we
pressed him he helped a little bit he
was just a dick and i remember being on
the phone and that happened to me again
in miami again with another person that
anyway and and he said to me and i was
like this is absurd i have all these
photos i'm going to turn and then i
think i'll take off like two nights and
i keep charging it next to nothing and
then he's like but the house is sick
though right
he said that to me i'm like what do you
mean like what do you mean it was but
the house itself nice piece of property
right i was like you are just a loser
like i'd like to buy a house in florida
should we great what do you think of
buying that i think i think great i
think i would too would you do it would
you buy a house in florida and airbnb it
because you know you would keep the
house clean your standards would you do
it or it's not worth it if it's strictly
an investment property to be a rental
i could picture doing it and just
getting a management company and hoping
for the best the management companies
suck too though they never helped either
they always pass the buck oh the owner
must not have the pool's always broken
dude it's always broken and they always
go it must have broke between you
the last guy and you because it wasn't
broken last week i've heard that five
times five times because the management
would have to pull down people down here
to service it and then people come
they're like yeah we haven't been here
or whatever yeah like one time i went
and i went and we we got this place in
reinbeck
same thing like 20 people 20 family
members we got there the pool filter was
broken and there was just tons of dead
snakes and frogs in there dead snakes
rhinebeck's in upstate new york though
beautiful yeah i love rhinebeck but
problems out the yin yang so ryan back
when i said we played a school called
called the bard university alma mater of
barbara walters
bard university we played bard college
um they were one of the first colleges
in the country in the entire world
actually to legalize marijuana on their
campus you were allowed to have
marijuana on their campuses
like 20 years ago wow so bard college uh
they beat us in the hudson valley um
conference championships at the buzzer
we lost in a buzzer beater um we lost um
remember it still did colin orcott hit
the game-winning shot he's my nemesis um
i remember all of them i remember the
coach chris williams i remember one of
their best players name is adam turner
they had a transfer student named joseph
waldense i mean nemesis is this just you
is this were they a rival of yours or
would you why do you remember this
because of the buzzer beater because the
buzzer being is just the pain and we
used to play them every week no well
they were in our conference
and and we just you know we would just
go wild and um yeah bard college and um
and
one one year we played them and we
stayed at the rhinebeck inn or the
rhinebeck motel and what happened was is
i was a freshman or a sophomore peer
pressured and what we did was again
being very stupid i want to do this now
but you know 18 year old kids the owner
of the inn
or hotel waited for us to get there was
like a snowstorm we had a game the next
afternoon so we got to the night before
just gave us all the keys and coaches
and said i'm locking up just he told us
college kids like i'm gone there's
there's nobody from the hotel here so
get your vending machines order your
pizza there's nobody here i'm locking up
i have to go home to my family yeah i
think i might remember this is this it's
crazy crazy so what we did was is all of
us went crazy the coach then told us
being like you know you guys are men i
trust you
so we said yeah absolutely so he goes to
sleep we then proceeded to almost the
entire team filed into one room so like
20 guys found into one room we all
pissed
in the uh heat like the
the uh radiator radiator piston radiator
about five or six guys took shits in the
sink
just went crazy why
for no reason then we turned the heat up
we turned the heat up as high as it
could go like hot like just broke the
dial then we let this was at like four
o'clock in the morning we left at about
nine a.m we get a call did you not think
we didn't think anything we're dumb kids
don't say anything we even forgot about
laughing we get a call
about the game was at one o'clock get a
call about 12 15 or the coach does for
the school he goes everybody in the
locker room right now
he goes
the rhine back in is on fire what did
you guys do
and then
nobody knew to say what to do and then
they said i remember i'll never forget
my friend brian i actually forgot his
last name we played basketball together
those years remember the whole opposing
team though yeah i remember the whole
bunch brian goes he goes listen i don't
know if it's this he goes but i'll be
honest
he goes you know i'm a senior i'll be
honest he goes a couple of us piss and
[__] in the radiators and then we turn
the heat up he goes he goes
and then the coach is like i'm taking a
wild scam
yeah yeah he goes but i don't think
that's it so funny coach is like why
would you guys do that and we were like
he left the property unattended and then
we lost that game and i remember being
in so much [__] trouble
dude i remember i mean what i used to do
i was one of those kids where even
though i was in college because my
college was small i acted extremely
immature until i was like 21 years old
like i acted like i don't want to act
like i'm not i'm above not being being
immature at that age but it wouldn't
occur to me to piss and [__] in the
radiator and turn up the heat and leave
i just wouldn't do that yeah it was very
stupid and here you are moments ago
saying if everybody was like me
wow wow
that's right we would i'll tell you what
kettle black that's what it is good bar
shout out i like the kettle black better
in staten island they do in bay ridge
wow um but um but yeah wow brittany what
is this britney spears showing off her
booty and red hot instagram pics what
the hell brookie's free now britney's
free and doing it so she's just posting
butt pics whoa whoa hey there you go hey
she looks great good for her i think she
also posted a full nude at one point
people are a little bit worried a full
mood
a schmood good for britney though on her
regular channels you can't go butt naked
on instagram can you yeah don't you get
taken off
she did let's see oh my god dude three
days ago
wow that thing that's gonna live forever
no i could somebody had to screenshot it
i'd like to get britney spears on the
podcast
oh that's a dream britney spears and
gary busey sitting down juicy i can get
i know i know yeah but you said yeah
yeah you might want to take it take a
pause on that [__] he's a tough guest
tough guest in the best way but yeah
they might have ripped them no one can
speak for him well i'm happy that
britney's out of her little thing now
nobody got it let's see i got to find
him it might be one of those things
where like this is social media pressure
or like you know public pressure and
again i don't know the ins and outs but
it seems like you know it's like what is
comes first chicken or the egg like
because of her conservatorship did she
go crazy or did her family put her in
this because they don't know what the
public knows and he was like my daughter
has mental health issues i need to save
her and now you took her off and now
she's screwed like what you don't know
which is which is which you know yeah
see she posted this of herself
but with the things over it yeah
yeah oh she put the heart there i think
so but i believe so but it's still is
that a tattoo
no but what yeah that's no no no on the
left and right
and what's is the caption like get
vaccinated what's the caption
did you write the caption in spanish no
no somebody reposted that would be
hilarious though she's got two crosses
down there
interest well listen you know
what do you think of that tattoo chris
you have crosses on your back i have a
cross on my back she has it right in the
crevice me and britney spears were made
for each other
imagine she had a jaden smith tattoo on
your thigh
would you ever get mad yeah i would i
don't there is one other person with it
oh there's a guy that volunteered when
we did um a special episode with the
military okay we did a live episode with
the military we blew uh we blew up
actual jeep with a tank and that's
hilarious and a guy got all three of our
tattoos that we got on the show they got
them too so one guy has the exact same
jaden i have shout outs to whoever you
are wherever you are thank you for your
service that's huge
um but i mean if if somebody like cardi
b
or her yeah if they posted that why
would it be an issue no it's not i don't
have a problem with it i think i think
can you go back a second
now is that the same picture as the one
prior no this is a different photo set
but it's the same song oh yeah
so different angles wait who's taking
that photo
is that the camera on that he looks like
a camera in a self-timer wait go go back
is that the camera on a tripod right
there in the mirror yeah yeah i think so
ah so she's got a tripod for a phone and
she's okay and it looks like she has the
same battery you do looks like she's got
the battery pack by the way that new
battery apple what are you doing apple
if you're listening and we know that you
are what's the problem with it okay so i
i buy it and i'm like okay because you
know they used to have the packs the the
case with the phone like a yes love that
yeah it's easy
you just set it and forget it right they
didn't make it for the new 12 or 13. now
there's this like
mag
magnet like a mag circle on the back and
they said it's going to be for all
future things like this so this is the
battery so now i'm like oh cool you
don't have to keep it in the battery so
you can keep it slim okay just throw
this on whenever you need it i get it i
thought this thing charges the phone 40
percent
to max capacity 40 and i was like this i
got a dud so i was about to take it back
yesterday and i just googled let me just
google it and it gives you the battery
life for each model and for my model
this gives you 40 battery why even put
the product on the shelves yeah
who wants it what's that what do you do
for me because they want you to buy the
holy [__] one that could probably give
you 100 which is probably this is
already a thing it's already like heavy
and stuff and i thought it was gonna be
like oh great i can it's one full charge
i think is the baseline no right 40
it's also it's also that doesn't really
with the sleekness of apple with the
sleekness and how things are getting
smaller that seems like something that
should have been around 10 years ago i
know it's bulky
i don't know who's you know apple who
was in the creative meetings with that
but that's not a good product i don't i
don't think that's a big seller make any
sense the air the air tag is great
[Laughter]
yeah the air tag is good but yeah that's
that's what's going on imagine that's
what this is an airport she had an apple
air tag right in her thong it would work
now my my uh dream for this year is that
her and kanye get together well no oh
that would
break the internet conyers that would
break the internet
it was julia fox yeah i love that chaz
commentary liked this photo by the way
[Laughter]
i love him shout out to gotta say she
looks spectacular she looks fantastic
she always has babes let's talk to you
about headspace we love headspace here
at the hey babe pod you ever feel like
your mind doesn't have an off switch
which is how i live my life uh crazy
adhd well the tension's constantly
traveling through your body which is how
he lives his life yes or do you feel
tired no matter how much you sleep which
is how we live both our lives that's
just a few of the many ways that stress
anxiety and sleeplessness can harm you
and harm your mind and your bod this
year why not make small changes to your
daily routine that have a big influence
on your mental health and well-being
sounds good to me start your year with
headspace we all say fine when we don't
mean it fine isn't really an emotion is
it how many times have you told yourself
you're fine when all you've really felt
is anger sadness or nerves most of the
time headspace is scientifically proven
to help you manage your feelings and
your mental health hello science fact a
recent study proved in just two weeks
headspace can reduce your stress by 14
times deal with it whether you want to
relieve stress and anxiety sleep better
or improve your focus headspace is your
everyday dose of mindfulness for real
life so i started using it and there's
they have all different courses all
different things you can do there's one
called the appreciation course love it
that is my current fave right now uh it
just cheers me up no matter like it just
really takes me out of
my head space and puts me into a better
head space and i know i'm making a
little fun with wordplay there but it is
true it is it's nice to have an outlet
it is and however you're feeling try
headspace at headspace.com hey babe and
get one month free of their entire
mindfulness library that's headspace.com
hey babe one month free this is the best
headspace offer available so go to
headspace.com hey babe today get ready
for the ultimate cozy winter night in
brought to you by beam beam is a
functional wellness brand that makes cbd
products to help you pursue your better
your better and push the boundaries of
what's possible for a limited time only
beam's best selling sleep product dream
powder hot cocoa which is my favorite
thing and i know you told me about that
okay now comes in delicious white
chocolate peppermint holy cow get me it
get ready swirls of peppermint mix with
creamy white chocolate for a guilt-free
hot cocoa of your holiday dreams and i
you know what even though it's january i
still rep the holidays
you've told me so much about this hot
chocolate dead seriously okay i got my
first bag i opened it i was like i don't
like this i made a hot a cup of hot
cocoa
it was delicious i sipped it in the
evening and then that night i had the
best sleep of my life seriously i love
it and you know i even you know instead
of uh twirling it with the spoon i got
that thing that you make the frost milk
with that thing looks like
i put it right in there and the thing
looks like it's going around like a
tornado i love it and it's just it gets
mixed in dude can i take a package home
it's in a bag but i will scoop it out
and put it into a uh what you call bag
for you ziplock a ziploc bag shout out
ziploc they're not responsible
but yeah yeah well here what is it what
is the generic form of ziploc i don't
know a plastic baggie yeah a weed bag
i'll put it in
white chocolate peppermint dream powder
only lasts for a limited time so get it
while it's hot
just okay here's what you need to do if
you guys want some beam then you need to
go to
beam organics that's
b-e-a-m-o-r-g-a-n-i-c-s
dot com slash hey babe that's
b-e-a-m-organics.com
h-e-y-b-a-b-e for 40 off the first three
months of a peppermint dream
subscription plus
free mug and frother yeah so they give
it to you or 20 off a one-time purchase
pause or cancel anytime i'm telling you
you will love it i love it try it
she always has good fire good good for
britney spears do you know what it would
take for me to put my ass on the
internet like that what would it take i
don't think it could happen
you would never do it i it would be an
amount that people would think is
unreasonable 25 million dollars it's
still up oh and it's uh that's her own
pain
free woman energy has never felt better
god bless hey you know what i respect
that you're free baby now let's say we
all go home
and then chris posts this same thing
would you be worried
and he's holding his nips he's doing the
same thing there's a heart over his
and the caption was just you know check
out my new dates christy comedy.com well
i think you should do it because i would
get traction
that would be you'd sell out everyone
sell out everyone yeah because so many
eyeballs would be on the side mimic that
exact thing i'm surprised people haven't
done it already i'm sure they have
that's what the internet is can you say
google
by the way iphone 11 she's using
not good
i mean what's going on here yeah there's
two models past that well she's been
home a lot do you think her screen's
correct
i will tell you the resolution the
resolution is not impressing me
no you know and i i mean
britain spears has to still have a uh uh
i mean an insane amount of money right
oh yeah yeah i mean i don't know what
the rule is like if her dad robbed
everything from her but
like people like let's say like jessica
simpson right she was very very very
popular for
quite some time right now i don't hear
anything maybe it's just me out of touch
but i don't hear anything of her is she
still sitting on i think you have to
invest well right is that it i think a
lot of them invested well i would
imagine i would imagine she has to have
a ton of money yeah i think at that
point you just had enough like you don't
need to keep up that touring schedule
that where you always hear like people
like brittany or other people they they
get hospitalized for exhaustion like i
was i've been close to that right i have
and i've been thinking to myself too
like when does this end for me right am
i doing comedy until like croak
like when does it end when am i gonna
say you know what
i want to not be in the public anymore
well here's the answer i mean this was a
week ago
inside the 11.5 million dollar house
jessica simpson
that just came up randomly yeah no
because you're listening to us yeah yeah
they're listening wait she's just bought
all right so she's
she's just bought an eleven and a half
she's in the bloomberg newsweek so
that's good to go i'd say she's good to
go it's a right is that a clothing line
to the right yeah so she risked her
house i guess she i don't know somehow i
don't know this is saying she risked her
11 million dollar house for her brand to
be saved
that's the story they're running oh so
let's see what that's about that and
that was from five days ago no three
days ago she's good then
billion dollar fashion brand back
and she once considered borrowing
against her homes
plural even though i have to go she can
considered she goes even if i have to go
live in a tiny little place in ireland i
will why ireland i mean what a random
what what i don't even have to go live
in a little tiny place in ireland
in a lengthy interview with bloomberg
the business mogul i guess she's i guess
she's has i guess she's out of singing
and she's has businesses she's a mogul
what makes you a mogul
i think to really like take ownership of
something and be successful at it like
entrepreneurship i would imagine like i
think that you
it's says business mogul so she's got to
have
multiple successful businesses in 2014
it said her clothing line had one
billion dollars in sales in 2014.
one billion dollars in sales
what where did she sell her products i'd
never heard of that before there must be
a girl thing
that they know jessica simpson's
clothing lineup my son
a lot of celebrities by the way does she
own forever 21
no a lot of celebrities have stuff like
that every there's so many celebrities
have their own rose tequila all that
[__] a lot of them have clothing lines
like reese witherspoon has a clothing
line you know how i found that out i
walked into a store in nashville and
they're like this is reese witherspoon
store yeah you know everybody's got
their hands just that's what
um
uh baby food line nature's organic that
like oh and what's the name alba has
a billionaire jessica alba it's not just
gabriel just alba has the baby food no
it's everything now it's cleaning
product it's everything you think of
honest you guys want to see 17 weirdest
celebrity side hustles let's do it let's
do it we got what's up here we have
people we have we we don't have peanut
butter we kind of had once that peanut
butter i want to get back into this the
peanut butter she hit me up i mean we
could what she said
i don't know she wants to talk yesterday
i i don't know who asked me my cousin
asked me we were talking i go i wonder
if that peanut butter is still for sale
i went on home page home
still do the page
just start taking some prop i mean you
know
it's time to it's time to listen we gave
you all of 2021 for charity sound time
to better spend start to start a side
business
all right what do we got carmen electra
and kendra wilkinson both sell stripper
poles okay
elizabeth hurley has a line of organic
snacks and beachwear called duchy
wait organic snacks and beachwear or
independent
also elizabeth hurley someone i haven't
heard from in quite some time i love
turning the austin powers gorgeous
gorgeous woman venus williams has an
interior design company that's okay
unbelievable i wish i could do that yes
that's what i feel like
that's what i feel like i would do don't
judge by this room please what do you
what would you like yours if you could
have a side business what would you do
i've i've answered that question a
hundred times do you think is it out of
the wrong possibility
no i just mean if i wasn't doing what i
was doing no i'm not i'm talking about
let's current status you what you you
it's it's very within the realm of
possibilities
i think you should you should diversify
you opened up a beer business but it was
a lot of work and then like two years of
covert and he's like i don't want to do
it anymore right you know but it was he
revitalized the staten island brand it's
no small feat
is that an official announcement what no
he he announced that already
yeah like a few months back he he just i
think he might still sell but i don't
think he's like going to continue on but
it was a lot of work it was a ton of
work and then like and a big investment
up front money up front but it was it
was good it was very successful but
covet calvin it'd be great yeah you
should make a sauce or something yeah
make a sauce make up maybe some type of
hair product oh so you think i'm going
to be fighting for retail shelf space i
think that sal with his with your name
and likeness should have a side business
going
i think you should what would it be i
don't know i think somebody like you
maybe an interior design maybe a nice
candle yeah but i can't
candle company is easier i think it
can't sound good i interior design you
have to give up your life i mean she's
probably worth venus williams is
probably worth what 500 million dollars
so i mean i'm sure she like hires the
right people then attends some meetings
and launches it right i feel like you're
paying for the walk through with her
yeah right i can't do that kevin
costner's company helped clean up the bp
oil spill and he has a casino i know
about his casino it's for sale it was
for sale i wonder if he sold it it was
in um
uh it was in tombstone
tombstone arizona really tombstone yeah
the guys went to we were on tour on the
bus we had two days off i split and went
somewhere i went to uh i went to
minnesota actually
what i went to minneapolis why on the
outskirts of it i heard this really
awesome like bed and breakfast so me and
and uh my lady went just to have a day
in a new city to venture around and it
was really cool was it worth the flight
from the tombstone arizona to go to
minneapolis we weren't there we we bust
somewhere and then we split and they
went to tombstone uh
murr and q went to tombstone to and they
went to the casino and everything and it
was for sale and they seriously
contemplated buying the casino really
yeah i it must have been like manageably
priced because
wow
look maybe you've been in breakfast type
in kevin costner casino i wonder if he
sold it
kevin costner casino price as well too
pretty sure it was in dead deadwood or
tombs deadwood
castle closed the doors in august of
2017. this building has been for sale
ever since a new company called lamar
feed and grain has stepped up purchase
price is 1.6 million it was 4 billion no
million bro see it was
oh are we gonna buy kevin costa's and
where was it
i know right
do you want to do this right now it was
on sale
deadwood that's it i knew it was uh it
was it was from the tv show why has
nobody bought this thing yet i don't
know
28 years of operation
why would nobody buy a casino at 1.6
million
it must have been a losing proposition
probably no that was on sale though in
2017 on tour interesting ever wonder
where akon's one-of-a-kind bling comes
from yes i do look at what he's wearing
he's wearing a singular diamond the size
of a grapefruit on a little chain
is that fake is that photoshopped
that can't be real it can't be real he
bought a diamond mine
what oh no that's a whole nother set of
issues unless he's regulating that
in 2005 the rabbit behind such hit smack
that and i want to love you bought a
diamond mine in south africa
really when asked how he acquired it
akon replied it's real complicated you
can just know that i own it that's not
good
complicated for us or him
akon wears diamonds that only come from
his mind okay in 2007 when people found
out about his purchase akon got into
some hot water
by claiming that he didn't believe in
conflict diamonds oh boys
said think about it ain't nobody thought
about nothing about no conflict diamonds
until the movie came out
wow
locked up
i mean that is rush limbaugh
company
didn't rush limbaugh he's gone now right
yeah i think he yeah rip two if by t was
the name as a reference to paul revere
wow sandra bullock owns two food-related
businesses in austin texas ooh maybe
i'll check him out let me just tell you
i love sandra bullock love sandra
bullock adam ray our good friend adam
ray on his podcast yeah how did you do
that adam go check out adam ray's
podcast yeah yes how did he do that
kelly ireland isn't just a kathy she's a
oh sorry kathy ireland um she's a
billion-dollar product licensing
business what wow i still have our
sports illustrated from 1994. really
yeah you just stuck together it was on
the cover
no
but it's got somewhere yeah
kathy ireland launched a product
licensing company called catholic
ireland worldwide after getting clothing
in kmart in 93 because of her socks
wow
wow wow
brings in 1.5 bill
in 20 countries
that's what you got to do man you got to
get behind we have to do let's do
something
what do you want to do seriously what we
have to fill a hole in the market that's
how it goes jessica alba
clint eastwood
has a golf club in dairy farm wow okay
like in the same place
yeah what about newman he had all he had
all paul newman
you know he had a lemonade
i thought she meant the guy from science
it wasn't just lemonade
yeah there it is yeah salad dressings
it's and a hundred percent of it was for
charity so we didn't give a dollar
credit wow and already after a year of
peanut butter were like give us the cash
wow wow it's pretty interesting justin
timberlake has a chain of hospitality a
hospitality company with a chain of
restaurants gwen stefani
lamb and jessica simpson jessica however
are two big exceptions to the rule both
are extremely popular so gwen stefani
stefani has a clue what it says to your
point pepsi says every celebrity has
their hands in the fashion industry but
most are not successful as you said
everybody's got fashion but only a
couple are it's the same thing with
podcasts everybody's got a podcast but
you know ashton kutcher and drew barrow
are big time production companies wow
they made donnie darko how much oh i
didn't know that how much is uh and
charlie's angel jessica alba worth
because that was like yeah drew
barrymore produced that yeah no no it
was right up in that same article bob
340 schmili wow
there you go it's her net worth not the
net would not is that the worth of the
company maybe is that what it is i don't
know yeah 340 million jessica alba
network yeah
340 mil
wow
it's it was a six million dollar seed
that gave back 340 mil
oh my god good for her and she is like
stunningly gorgeous and that's
timberlake's wife right now
okay
i'll tell you right now
jessica alba reminds me
of the fart lady's apartment
stunning
amazing
fart lady
if you're listening
i um and i don't mean to call you fart
lady but you are prevalently known for
that i don't remember i don't know the
name maybe that's the business then you
got the fart lady but do they have the
fart guy fart guy
could be me could be you seriously
can you what's the product that we're
going to have can you can you fall into
a jar next episode
and we'll just close it up and then put
it on ebay let me see if i can even
muster let me see if i can i don't have
to see what one goes for it's a one of
one
i mean i think you guys we need to do a
fart nft maybe
that's another thing that's solving how
do you get the fart into the jar
quickly enough
how do you there's got to she has to
have a technique she just have like a
conveyor belt just of well here i got
one blown up now
what's that
that was just that mic for that mic to
be his that was wet
is that worth it in a jar imagine that
got you a cool g a band as they call it
a band i had a a freaking penthouse in
the city
that that
you could have jarred that and we could
have seen how much he makes eight nine
grand on that somebody somebody
make no mistake
somebody would have bought that 100
just just for the fact of it's on the
show and and and they'd have
i mean oh god you know who would you
know who would buy because he has the
money tom brady
you would man and i want to say
congratulations i mean they won super
bowl
just having the money though doesn't
necessarily indicate that you'd be into
that for instance patrick mahomes has a
lot of money
i'd be remiss if i didn't mention him i
don't know if he'd use his money to buy
that i don't know if he would but tom
brady's a weird cat weird cat and i mean
listen
you know super bowl was in tampa he won
hometown team that could even happen
this year because they're talking about
moving the super bowl they may have
moved it already from los angeles to
dallas
um and it's it's it's possible to have
another hometown team and brady and my
homes are contenders they are contenders
when are they not the chiefs really
turned around this year they did shout
out to that organization shout out to
the chiefs i bet you the kansas city
chiefs will not be that they will not be
named the chiefs for much longer
we're gonna they're gonna something but
as a chief offensive i don't know if
it's don't even co-opt it at all i think
they just want it out right because my
dad would always call people chief but
he's not
on the native american right warlords
he's saying you know he's saying what's
up chief
right but that is because
that comes from that right i think chief
is a nice title you're the leader of a
tribe right right right you know yeah
good socks by the way thanks shout out
to only new york
i like these it is a streetwear company
in in uh they love the lower east side
and they they hook me up with a bunch of
stuff and i love their stuff it's called
only new york check them out it looks
like it like a like strep throat under a
microscope you know what i mean
something like that like oh [__] it does
a little bit like i thought it looked
like a colorful cheetah no it does no it
does do it looks it looks like a big gay
cheetah yeah that's what i was going for
just been hey babe
don't be a fake don't be a flake don't
run away from your feelings babe don't
be afraid don't be ashamed don't
hesitate to say hey babe hey babe hey
babe hey babe hey babe hey